demand for workers but the economy is  still about 9 million jobs  short of pre-pandemic levels job growth  has been widespread the biggest gains in  leisure and hospitality  education and construction bankrate.com  economic analyst mark hamrick says this  is a promising start  but we're not out of the woods yet yes  we had  many thousands of jobs recovered in the  leisure and hospitality segment which  has been the leading edge of job loss  but even with that there's still three  million jobs to recover  there alone this week president joe  biden unveiled a massive two trillion  dollar infrastructure proposal  the administration says it will create  millions more jobs